We're now going to take a look at how we can apply various static meshes as foliage.
This is actually quite easy to do.
The first thing we're going to need to do is open up the foliage tool.
Then once we have that open, we can actually apply any static mesh we want.
Let's take a look at how we do that now.
We're going to come over here to the editor and I'm going to get out of the landscape
tool and come down to the foliage tool.
Before I can use it, I need to bring a mesh down.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to hit control space.
I'm going to go to my starter content.
We're going to look for our, I think it's under props.
There we go.
I'm just going to grab this bush and just drag that right there.
Now, as soon as I have done that, I will be able to now paint this piece of foliage here.
And there we go.
Look at that.
I can use a shift to erase.
And I also have the ability to come in here and actually select the individual foliage pieces.
Let me just make sure G is on so we can see that.
And then I can do things like move this around.
I can rotate them.
I can even scale them.
And I can also delete them.
So this is really cool because this allows me to have finite control over a piece of
foliage and still use this tool to apply foliage to a massive area.
If we look further down, there are also a bunch of different options inside of the tool
that control things.
At the top, the painting, this is going to control the density.
And as well as the size of the various instances that we're painting.
So if I was to set this to 1.5, we would get some between 1 and 1.5.
Let me set this to 0.5.
Make it a little bit smaller.
There we go.
So we get a little bit of variety.
We also control the density and the radius here.
So the radius, if I was to set this to, say, like 200, what this will do is it will ensure
that they don't actually intersect with one another.
By providing a radius around it that it should spawn.
Now a great way to find this number here is if we just double click on this mesh.
Not that way.
Let's just browse to this.
There we go.
And if we look at the approximate size here in the Static Mesh Editor, it's 122.
So 122.
If we use that number here, that's going to be a great way to kind of use for our radius
for this particular object.
We can also add other objects by simply just dragging and dropping right there.
And then now we have chairs and bushes.
If we right click on the chair here, we can also remove it, or we can replace it with something else.
I'm just going to remove that.
I'm going to say yes.
There we go.
So what I want everybody to do now is just spend some time applying foliage to your project.
And this is what you can get.
This is using some content from FAB.
There's a few stones and things like that.
We're just all randomly scattered throughout using the foliage tool.
So I want everybody to take some time now to use the foliage tool and adjusted settings
and paint some foliage on your landscape and see what you get.